je vous préviens je vais pas dire
généralement nous à sam alors trouver un
restaurant dans le xiiième une balle
dans la tête en cette affaire est
décidément hors norme à tous on reste en
position à ce qu'on veut c'est un flat
globaux c'est le fric ne bouge pas
gergy bande ont reçu par nico les gens à
qui vous avez volé ce [ __ ] ils sont
dangereux
c'est pour tous mais les pierres
tout ça nous dépasse largement ils n'ont
plus ni la lucidité ni la revue
nécessaires à la bonne marche de
l'enquêté
tu vas faire tout ce que je t'ai dit
sinon tu vas vivre l'enfer ici
l'argent il vient complètement a tracé
un bon mot
rené coicaud muesser va pas entraver
votre enquête
mais
[Musique]
je